this is a production of Cornell
University
so this is the title today reputation
spill overs and looking at consumer
response to wine Appalachians and the
information that's embedded in those
wine Appalachians it just as as a way of
background this project is part of a
large multi or even transdisciplinary
grant from the USDA called the specialty
crops research initiative and I'm
involved in a few of these with
different people in horticulture and
food science this one is called improved
grape and wine quality in a challenging
environment in eastern US model for
sustainability and economic vitality and
the captain of the team is Tony wolf
some of you might know Tony he was a
student Geneva and there is a quite a
cast of characters from this department
and from food science some famous
horticultural scientists including me
and just Justine and Alan and you can
see down below these are the five
loosely related objectives that bring
together objectives that are important
to viticulturist in this case people in
the Horticulture Department food
scientists and then me as the social
scientist and my main objective in this
grant is looking at this question of
establishing a reputation for consistent
high-quality grape and wine production
in the east and these projects have been
involved with a few of them and you tend
to have your bright a proposal where you
have these objectives that are loosely
connected and then you go off and do
your disciplinary research and towards
the end of the project you start to sort
of find ways to bring your results back
to the same page and to tie and
integrate these things back together and
and I think we're making pretty good
progress on that front with this grant
so reputation and the question here one
of the questions here is how do you
create a reputation for for
horticultural products for horticulture
firms in this case it's wine and wine is
kind of a nice case to think about
because in the wine industry there's
both firm reputations that can be
influenced by the terroir by the soil
the climate
it can also be influenced by what the
wine experts are writing about and
there's some fairly influential wine
expert rating agencies in the United
States as well as other places other
good press past vintages all have an
influence on firm reputation and then
economists also talk about collective
reputation which is the reputation for a
group of firms in a similar Geographic
unit it's not always geography that
holds them together sometimes it's part
of an industry but in in many cases a
collective reputation is for a group of
firms in a geographic unit and in
addition to those things that influence
firm reputation here we also see things
like the name of the a VA or the press
or the wine scores for that a VA and if
you're not familiar a VA is the
abbreviation for an American viticulture
area which is a which is a geographic
unit that's been identified by the TTB
which is a sub part of the US Bureau of
census many of you are more familiar
with these than I am but it's a good
example of a well defined geographic
unit and we think or we propose that
this collective reputation for a group
of wineries might also be influenced by
that a VA making a link to another
Geographic unit somewhere else in the
world that's more established that has a
better reputation that's more famous and
we think that this having this
reputation linkage to another part of
the world might be more important for an
emerging wine region like New York the
captain of this project is from Virginia
and so Virginia is another burgeoning
versioning wine district in the United
States and and there's a question how do
they develop a reputation so this is
this idea of reputation spill overs
tying the reputation of your emerging
wine region or established to somewhere
else in the world and are there benefits
are their economic benefits to doing so
but like a lot of things there's laws
there's laws about how far you're
allowed to do
Sydney in 2006 United States signed an
agreement it was titled an agreement
between the ec in the United States on
trade in wine and it was amended in 2010
within this you know 300-page legal
document there was I think probably too
many words they could have condensed
this so for instance article seven if
you can bumble your way through the
article seven states that certain names
may be used as names of origin for wine
only to designate wines of the origin
origin indicated by such a name those
listed in annex for Part A names a
quality and it goes on and on kind of in
this circular language but there's very
strict guidelines about what information
you can put on a label okay so there are
in fact when you look at this annex for
there's hundreds of protected EU names
that can't make their way anymore onto a
front or a back label in the United
States of the wine product okay and some
of these are kind of these reputations
spillover words you can't use those on
the front or the back labels on wine in
the United States so so for instance I
used to live in the Central Coast this
is one of my favorite wines back there
and you can see that in 2006 a winery
outside of Santa Barbara would you might
not be able to see this but they
explicitly use the word roan on the
front label you can see that and then
the same wine in 2007 that was the last
year before they were told by the ttb to
stop using these protected names on
their labels you can see on their 07
label they actually go a little bit
farther and then you shut enough to pop
and the Rhone Valley on their front
label guy and in their 08 label which
hasn't come out yet won't have any of
this type of words on the front label or
the back label okay so there are these
regulations but when we look at into the
world I still see a lot of non label
references to these reputation spill
overs if you will okay so in the
Anderson Valley just a little bit west
of Sonoma
there is a festival every year called
the Alsace varietals festival so it's a
festival of those varietals that come
from this part of the world the wines
though are not from this part of the
world the wines come from Oregon
Washington there's a few New York
producers that go to this festival
there's a lot of California so they're
they're sort of borrowing goodwill in
the reputation from this area to
advertise their wine festival and
further down it's in Southern California
there's something known as called the
hospice Tyrone which is another wine
event that again borrows this very
famous name from France and uses it to
to celebrate to promote the wines you
know this one's been happening for 20
years this one is in its seventh year
annual festivals so there's there are
these examples of these reputations
spill overs in the world just they're
not on labels of wine okay and so we're
curious this is all in California we're
curious that this hat also can be used
as a marketing tool in emerging wine
regions so our research question and
then we want to see how consumers real
live consumers respond information about
reputation spill overs and to see if
when they're exposed to this kind of
information does it influence their
demand for the wine or the price that
they're willing to pay for the line and
if I could just have an aside this this
type of question is the type of question
I usually try to have in these
transdisciplinary big research as an
economist or someone interested in
marketing when i'm working with
horticulture people this is kind of
bringing the the research back to what
it means to to real consumers and how to
consumers respond to technology changes
or how to consumers respond to
information or to higher quality
products okay and then in addition to
this question or as a sub question we're
interested to see if this response to
wine information about these reputation
spill overs if it's the same for all
types of people for all types of wine
and if that information affects these
people in the same
I okay we go into this thinking perhaps
that this type of information these
reputations spill overs might be more
important in emerging wine regions and
we think that it might be more important
for people who know something about wine
perhaps but that's that's an empirical
question and the approach we use and
this is an approach I've used a few
times on the last few years over in on
the other side of the quad in the
basement there is a lab for experimental
economics and decision research and
perhaps some of you have participated in
the basement I'll show you a few
pictures in a minute and we invite
consumers into this lab pay them and ask
them to participate in some sort of a
consumer study in this case we're going
to ask them to submit bids for some wine
products and then different treatments
have different information and we try to
tease out the influence of the
information on their valuation of the
wines so it's a it's a lab experiment a
consumer lab experiment we brought in
260 for people to this and that's if you
can get I think because wine was in the
title of the flyer I think that helped
us in our recruitment efforts but that's
a pretty good draw so 264 non-student
that's fairly important so it's
important in several ways but not so
students you know there's some students
in the room no offense but students
don't always reveal their information
sometimes they're there in the lab
perhaps to just get the prize money and
go some of them haven't developed a full
how do you say full appreciation for
wine so it's hard to really include them
in the mix and a lot of students are
less than 21 years old and and it was a
lot of work getting the permits from now
i'm not sure if you've ever dealt with
her read about the State Liquor
Authority vs LA I think that took a
couple years off the end of my life
trying to deal with them and all their
permits and
so anyways we got a permit that would
allow us to auction wines but we didn't
get a permit that allowed us to sample
wines which was nearly impossible
because it was in the middle of a
workday we ran these from noon to one
and it's probably not productive to send
people back to the office after and what
we do is we brought them in and we asked
them to place bids on seven white wine
so seven commercial white wines from
three different US regions okay so we
had three bottles of chardonnay one from
California went from Oregon and one from
Virginia we had two bottles of Pinot
Gris one from California one from Oregon
then we had two bottles of the only a
one from California and one from
Virginia seven bottles is this where I
tell you they all have relatively we
really went out of our way to find seven
bottles of wine that had fairly simple
labels they didn't have cute animals or
not a lot of colors they really were
mostly text they were all from 2009 and
every wine bottle received at least one
in most cases to wine experts scores in
the 80s and we took all of our subjects
through like sort of the introduction to
Robert parking Parker wine scores and
told them sort of what a 70s meant and
what have score in the 80s meant and a
score in the 90s so it was a bit of work
but we found these seven bottles of wine
that seemed to fit these these
categories so that we felt we were on us
relatively even playing field going into
this experiment okay so they had the
same information about quality it was
the same year and the labels were were
as much as we could control they were
the same there was some discussion
whether we should put the bottles in
brown bags so as to hide some of the
these nuances but in the end we thought
that might be a little weird to
consumers coming into the lab so we
decided just to leave the bottles so
that everyone could see them full
information and everybody all 264 people
saw all of this information
grad work was this all at one time and
where these mainly Cornell employees um
i would say that about sixty to seventy
percent were cornell employees not
faculty so i guess we've made fun of
students we can make fun of faculty to
there are weird sunday so we don't allow
cornell faculty sometimes they sneak in
but we don't let them come in we don't
let students come in so it was mostly
staff and then we also advertise on
craigslist so we had a lot of people
from Tompkins County Cortland County
come in yeah that's a little more work
so we have to help them with parking so
it's not a preference but but it's
something that we did and just to be
clear we brought these people in over
the course of four weeks so we'd run
these sessions Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday for four weeks to two of these
weeks were and it was all during the
winter break when staff perhaps that a
little more time to participate in this
study that's a good question and then
these subjects randomly sign themselves
up to one of three treatments there was
three treatments the first treatment
there was really what we'd call no
information nothing more than the
information above my hand so they knew
where the wines were from they knew the
scores they knew what the labels looked
like they knew their from 2009 but they
didn't get any additional information
treatment to got some additional
information about the American
viticulture area and some technical
information about that a VA and then the
third treatment God information about
the same information about the ABA and
then we also linked that a VA to it
another region which was similar in some
regard to that a VA but that other
region was in France okay so in that
third treatment we were trying to make a
link to a region that had a longer a
more established a more famous wine
region okay so each of those seven wines
in the third treatment was linked to a
specific wine-producing region in France
okay and that was the difference between
these and we replicated each treatment
four times okay that's that's our three
treatments four times that gave us our
12 sessions and we had about twenty two
people calm there's 24 chairs in the
room 24 computers and we usually filled
up about 22 of them each day which is
pretty good but again I think it's
because it had wine in the title here's
what the room looks like in the basement
of warren hall when warren hall gets
done i think it's going to look fancier
but this is I think for instance these
privacy shields they're a little wonky
now I agree but I think when this room
gets built they'll be a much more
fancier enclosed unit some of these
experiments use sound so there's headset
there we didn't use sound I was just up
front explaining this as you can see up
front the different wines on display and
we asked everyone to look at them and
people pick them up and read read them
as they came into the room and we're
randomly seated at these different
stations and here's a close-up of what
it looked like a front we have the seven
wines every day we randomize the order
in which we held the auctions and then
every week we had a different practice
item so before these people sit down at
a computer and start submitting bids for
the wines we and it's a little bit
complicated they have to submit their
wine a bid on the computer in front of
them and it's a it's like a program like
many other things where it might not be
fully intuitive the first time so we
asked them to go through a practice
auction so they see how it works and we
always had a practice item every day
that we ran them through I don't have
time to talk about this today but
there's like a little sub experiment
going on here I've been I have a long
interest in the impact economic impact
of selling wine in grocery stores and so
my sub experiment is each week I had a
different I had a different practice
items so this particular week i was i
was selling bread and cheese so that was
sort of sending up this message that
perhaps wine and bread and cheese were
sold in my little store and
in warren hall and then another week I'd
have the line and then I had a bottle of
vodka and that would be the practice
item and another week I just have a
control item I think it was just a game
or something and surprising that what to
put here has a small influence on the
bids and more importantly what you put
here has different bids different
influence on the different wines and so
those wines from Virginia would be the
emerging region the wines from
California would be the established
region and people visit this is a talk
for another day but what do you have
bread and cheese here that had a
positive influence on the the wines from
the lesser known regions so if you were
a winery from Virginia and you were
selling that wine with bread and cheese
it had a positive impact it didn't
really have any impact on the California
wines when you had vodka up front up top
that had a slight negative premium make
a slight negative effect on the on the
on the values for the Virginia wines so
I'm not sure exactly what to make of
that but that's a sub another question
so everybody saw this map and this would
be the map to treatment 1 2 & 3 would
see treatment 1 this is all they would
see and so I would just tell them
there's two wines from our again there's
three wines from California there's two
wines from Virginia and then we'd move
into the auctions if you were part of
treatment to you'd see this map and then
I'd give you more information perhaps
too much information but I give you more
information about the specific
Appalachian so i would i would talk
about the San ian as a VA because one of
our wines came from talk about the santa
lucia highlands which is another a VA or
whenever i talk about the Russian River
Valley because one of our wines came
from that very specific a VA I do the
same for Oregon I talk about the to a
VA's and I do the same for Virginia I
talk about the very specific a VA's and
these are all all three of these are
maps that I borrowed from the wine
institutes in those different states so
they're all a VA
maps and if you're in treatment 3 only
in treatment 3 you'd also get
information about France okay and
specifically we would say that the three
varietals the Chardonnay the Viognier
and the Pinot Gris have this historical
roots in France and we talk about Alice
asus being the historical place where
Pinot Gris was first grown in market and
we talk about the two sub-regions with
in Alsace and that would allow us to
link the two Pinot Gris the Oregon Pinot
Gris to the top part of Alsace and the
california pinot gris to the whole ranch
the lower part of this appellation we'd
make this linkage same with the
chardonnays we'd make linkages to three
parts of Burgundy talk about others
linkages and the two vionnet's we'd made
references to the upper and the lower
Rhone Valley to try to enforce that
there was this linkage between those and
if there was any reputation spill over
that we could make that all make sense
it's a good place just I like to see an
odd gentle nod okay good so if you were
in treatment one you would see seven
bottles of wine you I would be standing
up front much like this and you would
have a computer that would have the same
information on your screen that I'm
showing and this is what you'd see in
treatment one you'd see the bottle we
talked about the state and the varietal
and that would be it and we'd ask you to
submit a bid that represents the most
that you'd be willing to pay for this
bottle of wine and if you're in
treatment to a very similar-looking
sheet but now you'd be given information
about the a VA and this is a summary of
the information that I give about the
ABA and I had a script that I stuck to
very carefully but I didn't overdo it
but it was a short script on that a VA
and then I'd show this math and I'd show
on this map where that a VA is and again
sticking to the script and if you're in
treatment three again you'd see this
you'd see this
information and now we would make this
link to the lower Rhone Valley Inn in
France the same sort of technical
information lead them to believe that
these were similar production regions or
had similar characteristics i think in
this case on the script said something
about here's Santa Ynez down near Santa
Barbara made the link to the lower Rhone
Valley we made some some reference to
the weather in these two places the
limited rainfall in these two places and
sort of the marine proximity to the
ocean we'd sort of have these types of
information that was technically true
and it was a way of connecting these two
and there are other people in the world
in tasting notes that have also made
these types of connections so it wasn't
i wasn't being completely fraudulent i
was using information that someone else
had proposed okay and then the
incentives i might have told you that
everyone coming into the lab got
twenty-five dollars to participate and
it took them about 50 minutes by the
time they sat down and went through the
the auctions and left the room $25 I
think that's fair some of my colleagues
are starting to pay more now and now
that's not going to be good because now
I'm going to have to pay more to keep up
with Harry and we told the subjects and
this is pretty important so we told the
subjects before we got going that for
every bottle of wine all seven bottles
of wine up front at the very end one
subject would be randomly drawn from a
drum so we had you know these 24 people
in the room and I had a big bowl of
bingo balls at the front labeled 12 24
and at the end i draw bingo ball and
that bingo ball person we would look at
their just just the administrators would
look at their bid and we'd also randomly
draw a market price for that bottle of
wine and and I also had a bag of chips
and all these chips had different prices
for the wines and so we draw a bingo
ball we draw a price so now I have you
know Ian's bingo ball and I
a price and so we privately go over to
ian's station and we compare his bid to
the market price and and here we go and
if Ian's bid was more than the market
price then Ian got the bottle of wine
but he paid the market practice and if
he ends all ready to pick on Ian but if
Ian's bid was less than the market price
there'd be no sale and in both cases
Ian's bingo ball stays out of the drum
for the next six drawers and it was a
way to really try to give people to set
the incentive so that they would bid an
amount that really did reflect the most
that they'd be willing to pay so they
knew that that's the most they'd be
willing to pay and at the end there's a
chance that they might pay that or they
might pay something less than that there
was a distribution of prices on these
chips that range sort of between five
and fifteen dollars I never told them
nap I'll tell you that now because it's
all said and done they just knew there
was a bag of chips up there that had
some distribution I told them it was a
distribution around the retail price for
these wines in truth it was perhaps a
little low cuz I wanted some people to
be you know when you pulled a five
dollar chip people were pretty excited
because they got a good day on it keeps
them coming back and that's how it was
done and this isn't novel this is how a
lot of these consumer experiments are
done in labs most economic departments
have one or two of these types of labs
doing similar types of experiments but
but not with wine and not with
reputation spill overs that I'm aware so
here's the data that came in so we had
an average willingness to pay across
everybody across all the wines was nine
dollars and six cents and there was a as
you would guess there was a distribution
around this some people had higher bids
overall some people had lower bids
overall there's a few people who come in
and just bid you know two dollars on all
the bottles of wine troublemakers so
I'll show you we have a way of sort of
filtering out those people but there
wasn't too many of those those types
there's also people had quite a wide
distribution some of the wines they had
a much higher valuation than others so
some people you can see over here that
people aren't that familiar with
Virginia wines on a scale of one to five
that was 1.71 and people weren't very
familiar with viognier it had a 1.8 4
out of 5 and so when that wine came up
on the auction block even though it is
quite a nice wine if I have some of my
office if you're curious we could that
one had a fairly low valuation overall
okay the Virginia viognier and a lot of
that I think was driven by this sort of
familiarity score so that 906 there was
quite a distribution around that around
that number people on average were 42
years old mostly females married
children at home there is a funny
statistic about one of the willingness
to pay when you have children at home it
goes up it's positive you know I have a
couple of children at home so I can
appreciate that and we did capture quite
a few of the of the you know
self-acclaimed wine consumers so we had
these people seventy-eight percent of
them called themselves the primary wine
shop or in their household we also
collect information about more
information on what I'm showing here but
we try to collect information about food
preferences food habits sometimes it's
interesting information to tie back to
think about the data and this is the
familiarity with the lines of Phil male
familiarity with the regions and then
this is the their average wine spending
habits so twenty-nine percent of them
spend less than ten dollars on average
when they go to the store sixty percent
of them are in the ten to fifteen dollar
range and then eleven percent are above
that fifteen dollars and you can see
that the average price here was nine
dollars in six cents and here they
self-report twenty-nine percent spend
less but again that's a little bit
skewed because this average has there's
a lot in that average and that
plays out and how they think about this
so the results some preliminary results
we found that relative to chardonnay the
Pinot Gris wines had about a 55 sent a
statistically significant premium about
55 cents per bottle and that's you know
that would be the Oregon and the
Virginia bottle the I'm sorry this is
the California in the Oregon Pinot
grease and so it was the California that
was higher than the Oregon but when he
pulled them together had a 55 sentry
miam wines from Oregon and Virginia had
bids that were statistically significant
and negative about a dollar five those
wines generated a discount of about a
dollar five relative to the wines from
California that shouldn't come as any
great surprise and then these treatment
effects that I went to great lengths to
you know set up this experiment think
about these treatments thinking that
people would have when I did this the
first time they're really it was kind of
sad but there wasn't any information
treatment effects so that was uh I went
home and sort of commiserated bottle
wine but actually then the next day I
got up and I thought you know that's not
that's not such a terrible finding
because it wasn't the fact that overall
we found that effect is kind of in line
with what we were thinking whether we
knew it or not but Mamie went to pool
Oregon California and Virginia together
you might not see this tie and in fact
it might be a confounding effect where
it was positive for some a negative
brother and overall you don't see it so
then we went back and we thought more
carefully about the wines from Oregon
and Virginia and when you separate those
wines from Oregon and Virginia because
they had these these bids that were a
dollar five less than the ones from
California we found that the bids for
those wines when you separate them out
those bids actually did respond to the
treatments they didn't respond to the AV
a treatment so when he gave him
information about Oregon Virginia and
you talked about the a VA s in those
regions because those regions aren't
very well established giving more
information about the region didn't do
anything to their bids but when you told
them about the a VA s and you told them
about how those abs are similar to these
a VA's and France then you found a
positive and statistically significant
effect on that treatment 34 those wines
so that's that to me is a that's
reassuring that's a good that's a good
result to me and then perhaps I think we
found that was about a 60 sent premium
for those wines so so if you have a
dollar five less overall and you can get
sixty cents from that back by having
this link to France among these 264 and
then furthermore we took the sample the
264 people and we split it in half
according to your familiarity with wines
so this would be familiarity with either
wine regions or wine varietals and it
didn't matter which way you split it on
either of those parameters but for the
half of people that were more familiar
with wine regions are more familiar with
wine varietals they also had a positive
a statistically significant and positive
effect on treatment 3 so again that
linkage to Europe had a had a strong
positive effect for wine aficionados if
you will and it had a positive effect
for those wines for Morgan and Virginia
okay and then it even had the strongest
effect among the wine aficionados on
their bids for those wines which we
think are the are the emerging wine
regions i think if you really enjoy wine
drink a lot of wine you might not think
Oregon is an emerging wine region but I
think too many of the people a lot and
when you look at wine shops in Ithaca
there's not a lot of oregon wine
available so I think it's fair to call
these two the emerging regions relative
to to France and California I always
like to finish a slot talk with some
implications I think it's probably just
my extension appointment hat going on
and what does this mean to to real
people what does this mean to some of my
colleagues involved in this project and
it seems that when you draw attention to
a BAS for wines from emerging regions it
really it's not it may knee isn't a good
use of your time and money if the if
it's an emerging region then the a VA is
probably even more emerging and sort of
dwelling on that type of information
doesn't seem to have an impact on
although that's the information you're
allowed to put on the label it doesn't
seem to have an effect doesn't seem to
impact consumer evaluation of those
wines and even amongst your wine
aficionados that pick up the bottle and
actually read the front and back labels
that still didn't have when you talked
about the Monticello a VA in Virginia it
just didn't seem to have doesn't
resonate with consumers the same way it
does when that a VA is linked to another
region in another part of the world in
our cakes to these well-established
regions and France okay and that that
really did resonate with subjects and so
if there is some non label way to do
this it seems to be seems to have more
bang for your buck in a marketing
strategy way I think I've said this but
this is just sort of trying to recap the
main punchline that it's it's these
emerging regions and it's these
consumers that have some wine knowledge
seem to respond most of this treatment 3
I think that's where I stopped I have a
big table of results I stuck at the end
because I didn't wanna someone told me
once that's not nice thing to do so I
have heaps of more results if you're
curious so I'm hoping to write this up
soon I've always got good comments from
horticulture faculty and food science
faculty so if there's any questions or
suggestions i'm happy to and Franny told
me that people would be excited if I
could stop before 110 guess that's a
problem but if you have any thoughts
thank you how about this just click
comment the reason you didn't put New
York in there eliminate bias by locals
who I know somebody
New York yeah that's a good point i
should have said something yeah there's
a home bias effect that sometimes can go
on and so here we are in the finger
lakes and i think at one point we
thought we might have included it and
then in the end it just would be hard
especially if you're just trying to
submit it to some journal and and they
see this home bias effect i think we
could have added it as at one point we
were thinking about adding a fourth
region might have been Washington it
might have been New York but in the end
it was this trade-off of the home bias
effect and then we felt that seven wines
for people who weren't great wine lovers
to surpass them to submit bids for more
than seven wines might be some fatigue
going on in the lab too but that's a
good question it's mostly this home bias
I think the wine states in the United
States the top is California the second
is Washington the third of the Oregon
the fourth is New York and the fifth is
Virginia and so we picked one three and
five as a way to motivate these wines
and that ordering changes a bit year to
year but that's sort of the 10 year
trend did
Jenny how about Han so I think where you
see a huge impact is
go past region and put a buzzword like
champagne
the names that are specifically ring
from the lesion
link to a region but the name itself was
really well done right I guess that's so
legal now
yeah so those macro regions it's it and
it's but it's careful it so it's a very
funny it's it's illegal to put that on
the on the labels or on your promotional
material but it's something that you're
allowed to talk about in the tasting
room it's something you're allowed to
put in your tasting notes it's something
you're allowed to name a festival after
you know so there's these the second
order of of information that that and
that's why it kind of ties itself nicely
to the this collective reputation where
so it's not necessarily something that
firm is promoting but a group of firms
at a festival or as part of promotion of
their appellation and sort of time at
Appalachian to some other part of the
world but then you're right there's this
degree of famous pneus regions and other
parts of the world and how do people
respond to those different and we
thought there might be something because
we thought that burgundy was more famous
than Alsace but we didn't find any
statistically significant difference as
to those three different regions in
France that we tie them to your right we
were confused with
this California for years so cheap wine
they call burgundy and it's within
Burgundy
yeah and then yeah then at one point we
were worried if we just send this
information without our pictures you
know with that influence and so maybe
maybe it's one of these things where
there was a visual plus some text which
we were able to include an ex about
Jenny they averaged four meals out a
week is that normal that high if it's
high with that increase or like inflate
the price that you're willing to pay um
yeah that's a good question and this did
we put that in this list and was in the
summary so in one of I think in an
earlier model we included that as an
explanatory variable and does the number
of restaurants per week influence your
valuation of these wines thinking that
people who go out more would spend more
on lines that I vivid wasn't in this
table which makes me think that it fell
out and it wasn't important so we we
asked them how many meals do eat for a
week and there's a drop down menu
between 1 and 21 and you know I was
surprised to see it for but I think you
know if you eat out at at school or at
work three days a week then
there's your where that number is coming
from it was a bit high though to me it
seemed high I don't eat at four times a
week so yeah and then there's a quality
of eating out we might have also asked
them what's your average spending on a
bottle of wine what's your average
spending at the grocery store or we
what's your average we asked them like a
survey some there's also serve a fatigue
I think I'm this one we asked them 35
questions and we asked some more
specific things in the end we know we
will use all this information but we
collected because we have them trapped a
sense to me actually the subjects
actually participate in your pissed and
must be a joke
if a subject like me no idea so that the
ABA whatever is useless to be a
gentleman so other innocent my question
for you actually are those how you
decide to choose the code in which
subjects yeah so that's good question so
they could of me actually so does do you
favor actually well the only way we
would recruit you is it well you
wouldn't be allowed because you're a
faculty member I just like a basement
bouncer at the door I have to know the
Lord generally so that's why you decide
that you this guy is knowledgeable or
this process knowledgeable okay so
that's a good question so in the flyer
in the call for subjects we were fairly
specific and we said we're looking for
we're running a wine experiment and you
have to have purchased and consumed
white wine at least once in the last two
months or something like that so that
was the criteria for signing up it's
hard for us to check that information at
the door but we also ask that question
in the survey and occasionally you get
people that when they answer that
question the survey is 0 then we r we
drop them from the from the regression
we drop that observation from our
analysis so we asked them how many times
a week do you drink or we ask them how
often do you drink wine once a day once
a week once a month to type of thing and
then we use that information that also
has an influence on willingness to pay
and in the regression we can you know we
can holding everything else constant
including this we can try to tease out
these
treatment effects that is a good
question that's sort of problematic and
i should say if i have one minute
[ __ ] standing up so you don't lose
everybody geneva before they ask their
questions oh ok so just i think to sort
of address this you'll see that in the
bigger model we have every time I report
results I have something called a full
sample which is everybody who came in
all 264 people and then we have this
restricted sample where we drop out
people who don't drink wine had bids
average bids less than three dollars
sort of these troublemakers they were
less than 21 years old but there weren't
any of those in the room but people who
didn't this is sort of a way of looking
at the more focused group that's a good
question so can we is there anybody in
Geneva as a pressing question valuation
of wines cranked to the Ryan and
familiarity with Chardonnay first
rehearsal yeah yeah so that's a good
question so we have that's something
we're going to explore more but we we've
started to tease out and found that the
the valuation of Pinot Gris was higher
than Chardonnay the value of viognier
was less but not statistically
significant but was less than Chardonnay
and so we're doing some of the things
I've been talking about here I've also
been doing by varietal so this is
typically how economist think about have
all this data and today I talked about
sort of the big picture results I talked
about the results for specific types of
people more or less knowledge about wine
or more or less familiar with wine but
that's a good sort of next step is to
think about do these treatment effects
differ based on varietals
and my guess is the general story will
hold up but that the general story will
be stronger for Pinot Gris and not as
strong for beyond yay but it's just
trying to think about what what story
how I want to slice and dice the data to
prepare these titles these tables which
way is most effective but that's yeah
that's a very good question and
something we're thinking about sort of
the beauty of having so many
observations as we can split the sample
in half according to these different
parameters how about behind the end is
there any reason why you show this
points for the ribs I mean your initial
example was a rib right right good point
um so at one point we thought well we
didn't want to mix whites and reds and
then we had to decide whites or Reds
originally we thought we were going to
have new york in the mix and we thought
that if New York was in the mix it would
probably be a reasoning that would be in
the mix and then they weren't and then
we just kind of got going with whites
there is there is and I talked to Tony
wolf about this last week there is a
thought that we would try to replicate
this with red wines which would be fun
if we found you know similar set of
results but but yeah I don't I don't
have a great answer why we start it with
whites I think we just kind of got going
and then we had done all this research
and found all of these wines and went
with it it would be curious that's a
good point how about
so you said that there wasn't much
effect from the ABA resignation curious
how sort of mud and emerging industry
while trying to maintain this quality
that's nice from a particular area you
know if you're getting lines from
outside monticello region and a consumer
sees that
like with all the garbage like this one
how you we maintain that quality
perception without
yeah so I guess I hope I understand your
question correctly but I think so we're
not advocating that you sort of abandon
the promotion and the work that goes
into developing an AV a but in addition
to that I think we think that to sort of
give a kickstart to an emerging a VA to
bring in this the sort of outside
information might and maybe this helps
answer your question but we found that
the value of the ABA actually was
stronger than the link for the
California wines so in a it's not really
part of the set of results it's sort of
a second level of results but the value
of the a VA was actually more important
for California one for all three wines
in California then was the link to
burgundy Alsace or the Rhone Valley so
it's again it's sort of thinking about
you know developed wine region versus
emerging wine region the level of
aviator using for California with the
generic like Napa Valley not los
carneros Custer said that were you it
was so I was fairly specific so and in
fact the bottle of wine maybe I showed
you as echo Mesa said the Santa Ynez
Valley right on the bottle of wine I
encourage them to read that and then I
showed them a blow up like this on there
and so I said this is the Santa Ynez
Valley I showed them where it was down
near Santa Barbara and I did the same
thing for a Pinot Gris that came from
Monterey but it wasn't at Monterey ABA
it was from santa lucia highlands which
is a fairly small and then I did the
same for the Russian River Valley which
again is a you know some people might I
might have I didn't use the word Sonoma
I was pretty careful i just i always
said the ABA than I said the city for
which that a VA was close to so I never
actually ever said the word in Sonoma or
or napa
any treatment that's a good question did
you have a question over here assassin
okay how about who who buys the most one
you know who's the main consumer is it
male female because get seventy four
percent of your participant or female
they bought eighty percent of the wine
comes out yeah so that was a bit
surprising to me too so in states where
wine is available in supermarkets
females by a lot more wine than males
but in the state of New York men buy
more wine than women so I was a little
surprised by that but you know that
might have been a response to my call
you know these people sitting in their
office they saw the call for this
particular and they said you know do I
qualify for this experiment that's not
exactly an answer your question but it
does it's I found that you know since
Prohibition stopped in this country all
these states have these different laws
about who can sell and buy and hours of
distribution all of your sort of wine
demographic information or either you
have this national demographic but then
each state it does change surprisingly
consumption changes a lot by state which
made me a surprising but it changes
quite a bit and the people who buy wine
surprisingly different across states how
about Chris
mentioned at the beginning that French
becoming quite restrictive and what
being allowed to be put on labels of
foreign life if we extrapolate New York
State okay you can put from Rhone Valley
or from some place in France on your
label would it help New York wineries to
have oh this is just like the one out of
the Napa Valley
yeah so that's a good interesting
question so that's like a replicated
amidst accreditation spillover and I
should back up and say that that
European agreement actually has all
major European countries has
restrictions on mosel valley from
Germany and pages from Italy it just
happens to be that France has the most
pages of of restrictions but that's a
very good question Chris because there
is a little bit of buzz in the
Monticello a VA they're calling
themselves the napa valley of virginia
and so you even see these little as
anyone from Virginia and if you've heard
that expression good good but it's not
done and it's sort of a promotional
effort I just hear people using this
sort of expression the first time I
heard it I was thinking huh that's uh
that's a curious domestic reputation
still over
but that wouldn't be legal on the label
but but again it's sort of these non
label references or non label promotion
efforts and every year when you have a
new label you have to submit your proof
to the ttb and they have to approve your
label so that it's very regulated so
Rani thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu